Les pirates infestaient les mers depuis des générations.
Je fis donc serment de les éliminer tous.
C'est là, qu'apparu ce gamin.
Jack Sparrow.
Suivez-le !
Il m'enleva tout ce que j'avais.
Et déclencha…
…ma fureur.
Les morts ont pris le commandement des océans.
Ils cherchent un navire,
une fille,
et un pirate.
On m'a compté la légende, d'un cruel capitaine espagnol qui traqua et tua des milliers d'hommes.
Non non non non, pas des hommes, non non non,
des pirates.
Des pirates !
J'ai bien connu un espagnol avec un nom espagnol.
Il en a après vous, Jack.
Où est votre bateau, votre équipage ?
Votre pantalon ?
Jack !
Toutes mes excuses, de quoi on parlait déjà ?
Il ne peut plus se cacher.
Trouves Sparrow pour moi.
À partir de maintenant nous sommes alliés.
Vu les circonstances nous sommes bien plus que ça !
Le macaque !
Je ne veux pas avoir de problème.
Tu ne dois pas t'amuser tous les jours.
Il paiera pour ce qu'il m'a fait.
C'est ça mon nom après Jack,
je nagerai jusqu'au rivage.
- Arrêtez, je vous en prie.
- Nan nan nan, l'arrêtes pas.
- Vous allez bien trop loin.
- Non pas du tout !
J'ai vu ses chevilles.
T'en aurais vu bien plus,
si t'avais fermé ton caquet.
Jack Sparrow
Tu connais ce pirate?
Seulement de nom.
Trouves Sparrow pour moi et transmets lui un message de la part du capitaine Salazar,
dis-lui...
...qu'il a rendez-vous avec la mort.
Tu peux lui dire de ma part?
J't'en prie.